singing the national anthem in belgium
but this of course is ukraine's anthem
part of a coordinated effort by europe
to send a renewed message of solidarity
ursula von der lion was wearing the
colours of ukraine's flag as she joined
other leaders in addressing the
ukrainian population
we can never match the sacrifices you
are making every day
but we can
and we will stand by your side
defending the sovereignty and
independence of ukraine is defending the
stability of our world
we will continue delivering weapons from
armoured howitzers to anti-aircraft
systems month after month britain's
prime minister who was in kiev on
wednesday promised ukraine every
possible military economic and
humanitarian support including new
drones or uavs
today i can tell you that more artillery
artillery more ammunition is on its way
and uh 2000 uavs
johnson's not been seen at 10 downing
street for a while he's been holidaying
before leaving office next month but
there's no missing the symbolism of the
flowers outside across europe then we've
seen ostentatious displays of support
for ukraine but as the war drags on the
international community's appetite for
continuing its military support to the
key of government could be severely
tested since february many european
nations including the uk france and
germany have provided weapons and
training directly to the ukrainian army
but last month europe's six largest
countries offered ukraine no new
bilateral military commitments for the
first time since russia invaded
and the struggle to cushion the public
from soaring energy price rises and
knock on from the conflict could make it
harder for political leaders to justify
more spending on ukraine now as we see
gas prices rise even further likely to
push europe into a recession this winter
we have elections coming up in
particular in italy that are going to be
quite significant
and where some of the right but not all
of them are are more friendly towards
the putin regime and i think the real
focus needs to be understanding that
there is this economic war going on
simultaneously
for now the words and gestures of
support show no sign of drying up
but what ukrainians might be tempted to
wonder is how long will the outside
world make sure their country can resist
on the battlefields nadine barber al
jazeera london